- [Sal] We've already had several videos
where we give an overview of the Crusades.
And just as a review, they
happen over roughly 200 years
during the High Middle Ages.
The first Crusade at very
end of the 11th century
and actually the most
successful of the Crusades,
allowing the Western European
powers to take control
of Jerusalem and much of the Holy Land.
And you could see that
here on this diagram
where Jerusalem, at least,
goes from green to red,
controlled by the Western
European, the Latin Christians.
And they're able to maintain control
through these Crusader kingdoms
all the way until 1187,
when Salah ad-Din is able to
retake control of Jerusalem.
Then a few decades later, as
we go into the Sixth Crusade
and the Barons' Crusade,
which isn't depicted here,
the Western Europeans are
able to take more control
but eventually, the Muslims
take control of Jerusalem
and as we enter into the 14th century,
they have control of the entire Holy Land.
Now while that is happening,
Constantinople gets sacked
at the end of the Fourth Crusade
by the Crusaders themselves
and even though it's retaken,
this is really the beginning
of the end for the Byzantine Empire.
So let's think a little
bit about how the Crusades
changed Europe and the entire world.
Well, one of the obvious
impacts of the Crusades
was just the amount of death it caused.
It's estimated that the
death toll from the Crusades
is two to six million people
just from Western Europe.
And just to put that into perspective,
the European population at the time
was about 60 to 70 million folks.
So we're talking about four to
10 percent of the population
dying in the Crusades.
And this isn't fully
accounting for all of the death
and destruction that happened
on the way to the Crusades
or that happened in the
Middle East as well.
If you look at this map of
what the region looks like
as we get into the 14th
century, right over here,
you can see that although the Middle East
is still in control of the Muslims,
Muslims have for the
most part been pushed out
of the Iberian Peninsula,
and they have a little bit
of a foothold right here in Grenada.
And this Reconquista is going to continue
all the way until 1492 when
what will be the Spanish
are able to push out all of the Muslims
from the Iberian peninsula
and as they do that,
they also expel the Jews.
You also have territorial
gains in the north of Europe
that's a little bit harder
to see on this map over here.
As I mentioned in previous video,
part of this Crusader
mentality was not just about
taking land back for the Byzantines
or taking land from the Muslims,
but also trying to take land or convert
what were perceived as
pagans in the north,
German tribes that had not as
yet converted to Christianity.
And so that helped for
territorial expansion
in the north of Europe.
Now a big theme in the Crusades
was the power of the Pope.
Remember, the Crusades
were started by a Pope
working people up, saying,
"Hey, let's go help the Byzantines.
"Let's go take back
land from the Muslims."
Pope Urban II.
And over the course of this 200 years,
you have this religious fervor
where the Pope is
organizing these Crusades.
People are feeling this religious spirit.
Many people are, before
going on their Crusade,
they're bequeathing
their land to the Church.
If they die, and many of
these lords do end up dying,
they're giving their
property to the Church,
headed by the Pope.
Kings also gained power
during the Crusades.
In other videos, we talk
about the feudal system
and many times the vassals to the kings,
the dukes, the counts, the barons,
often had more control
over their territory
than the kings might have had.
And they were constantly
squabbling with each other
but as people started
to focus their energies
on this external adventure
known as the Crusades,
first of all, many of these lords died,
their property went back to the state,
went back to the kings.
You start having less internal dissension.
In a way, this idea that
Pope Urban II thought of
at the end of the 11th century.
Hey, why don't I point people externally
so they stop worrying about
what's going on internally?
It kind of worked.
Another trend is the importance of cities.
In the feudal system, it's
all about these manors
and all about these estates.
But in order to finance the Crusades,
centers of trade and commerce
became more important
and also, as there was more interaction
between West and East and
more people traveling,
you can imagine that it fostered trade
which centered at these cities.
And that goes into the next point,
commerce and trade itself
was fostered by the Crusades.
It wasn't all fighting.
The Venetians and other
trader city-states,
they helped facilitate the
movement of arms and people
from West to East, but on the way back,
they also brought goods to trade.
And so they became much,
much more powerful.
In fact, by the end of the Crusades,
as we get into the 14th century,
Venice, which is right
over here on our map,
was considered the richest and
most powerful city in Europe.
Venice has all of this trader wealth
and it's not just from trade.
As you might remember
from previous videos,
when Constantinople was sacked,
it was sacked in part by
these Venetian traders
and after that, they built an empire.
They broke up the Byzantine empire
and took some of it for themselves.
And so it's not a coincidence
that as we get into the
14th and 15th century,
places like Venice and
Florence, famously sponsored
by the Medici family, a
famous banking family.
So once again, these are centers of trade,
centers of commerce became the places
where the Renaissance
would first flourish.
And last but not least,
as in some ways bloody
and dark a time as the Crusades were,
they were also associated with learning
because you had all of these
people go from Western Europe
to the Middle East and the Holy Land
and at that time, remember, we have videos
on the Golden Age of Islam.
In a lot of ways, they were
shepherding the knowledge
of the Ancient Greeks and the Romans
and they were merging that with knowledge
from the Indians and the Chinese
and also coming up with
innovations on their own.
And a lot of the Western Europeans
brought that back to Europe.